hello and welcome to this video playing
Grand Master geheime poets I let's see
what is doing the secret police got two
out of two I answer that's not so bad
let's hope I can keep the score the
percentage yeah I know that after Bishop
d7 95 is the critical move okay it
didn't do it okay so if i take as a has
some kind of some kind of discovery i
guess yeah not a form
interesting a group do you wanna be a
screenie seven interesting it's very
quickly developing if i take night if
for one
how do I keep my pawn structure intact
in this position 95 maybe it's maybe
interested anyway 494 it's naija for
move now is that just looking fancy by
the way by the way if i take p 7 I don't
see you isn't there are some kind of
tactic going on here with the long
diagonal 94 94 I guess 187 doesn't work
ok ok there is no fancy tactic working
so I just take the ball
yeah the 95 all that didn't lead to
anything and maybe actually 94 was
interesting sorry 94 though huh and that
avoids the issue okay let's go back
it's 97 or more fear may be alright
still equal ever three maybe every year
and that's it's still nothing input
nothing special
so toy with host a chief for ideas but
you can always just play 97 in those if
I if I should go for it maybe am before
v4 94 Bishop a one and then 97 494
yeah it's still slightly annoying for
sure
could be six or what is the deal my
ideas before now so that is getting out
of this this potential and always got
rope 280 course hmm there was a simple
simple way of doing it 95 is also coming
home check
night before what's the deal here I can
go Bishop g4 let's do that doesn't have
such a comfortable square for the Queen
en disposition
and night before just Bishop c5 winds
winter stuff
93 90 XD 3 yes 94 I don't know if that
does too much it's a bit y interesting
though at least maybe you can go if five
yes I definitely can do that
I know actually there's this some pins
going on here maybe that isn't so easy
if I take now and go e4 why am I not
winning stuff because of each five
bloody time or neg la dh5 and e4
immediately Knight takes wind stuff it
takes it and take f2 ok then I have to
try this eve 4-h 585 m and time time
bloody time yeah position is equal but I
spent ages trying to get something and
now I have no time yeah I hope it's
equal at least I mean double porn isn't
pretty
this doesn't look very threatening
here here wireless Bell probably sue
draw but I'm getting hit on the clock
now black research gym I don't know that
that is a weird outcome of the game he
just had a completely equal I mean I did
this can never be worse for black so
absolutely not I was trying to try to I
know get something here it took her like
he a knows those ideas but it didn't
work out maybe the engine wants to start
with this move and probably then bishop
t5 possible hmm this actually seems to
be quite strong where is he going if he
goes there I membership t4 and
yeah 3 c1 that was probably the way to
do it and here i don't have anything if
I've just work and here route III is
given as the best move by the comb which
is something I mean I kind of suspected
that but it felt so weird I don't know
ah here i can actually play better route
takes us better Luke takes chant end
play this I would you switch which is
totally equal the way it went here I
mean black at least has a symbolic
advantage but if I was just a bad move I
mean he has to king of seven or
something and then g5 and who wants to
go a five yeah no one I'm just better
and with no time I just go King f5 and
win stuff on the queenside he is hmm can
it will be at game okay but happy to get
a win in this year yes doesn't have a
name right nope okay well thanks for
watching